de 37 weezy et bienvenue sur west ham et
autres six as tu peur du noir si oui
pourquoi pas pourquoi tu t'es pas m'y
tiens avant tout à le commenter quand on
est énervé totalement ridicule en fait
je front juste les sourcils et j'en
trouve la bouche ce qui fait que les
gens qui m'énerve au lieu d'arrêter de
m'énerver
ils ont plutôt tendance à se moquer de
moi et c'est compréhensible mais c'est
un monstre de poursuivre et que perry tu
te suicider ou tu cours mais je cours en
manga je cours je veux vim
bon j'ai pas dit que je m'en sortirai un
mais au moins je courais ça c'est sûr tu
avec l âge à la naissance le même âge
que maintenant c'est à dire dix sept ans
oui je suis immortel
je me suis dit qu'est un temps mort
tu peux te faire la plus belle grimace
excusez moi mais bon tu fais pour
trouver des jeux toujours un solide mais
drôle alors je vais sur trois sites qui
regroupe plein de gens indépendants à
savoir game show indeed et bmod db soit
je mets dans la catégorie top freising
tu veux dire les jeux les mieux notés
dont classe coup j'ai une liste de jeux
qui forcément sont d'une qualité minimum
parce que vous savez j'en ai parfois
c'est quand même un peu à la limite du
nom je sois je fais toutes les pages du
site pendant trois heures qu'on ait
trouvé logique qui vous plaira et qui me
plairait aussi sur lequel est un moyen
de bien délirer en vidéo comment es tu
nous mets tes orteils
alors henri marcel wallon tard à nicolas
jacobs des quais tueur qu'est ce que tu
fais là j'avais tous vous tuer ah bah ça
va alors non que signifie ton image de
greffe il
attention préparez vous à une
explication nous aurons toujours une
chimère globale dans un cercle mais sans
la barre du milieu du lsc l'édicule bon
bref voilà c'est un logo qui date de
quelques années ou alors on va faire un
beau toujours très original tu dors avec
ou sans caleçon et le suspense est
terrible à l'heure actuelle
tada white au wat je peux te poser une
question donc tu t'es que nous la décrit
où il ya des choses fait pour ça et là
on est dans une sacoche tan tan
donc oui vas-y puis comment tu mets tes
chaussettes j'aimerais savoir comment tu
t'appuies il est vrai que je n'habite
pas comme tout le monde j'ai une sorte
de petite formule magique
quel bon café wa combien tu as dedans et
ben excellente question et bien-être
humain anormalement 32 dans un émoi en
fait on est rodé une et je vous jure que
c'est pas du fait c'est à dire qu'il me
manque une dent bon c'est pas comment ni
pourquoi
bref pas vrai et maman ont mal fait leur
travail du fait qu'à cause de l
adolescent j'ai dû me portait des bagues
harnes double merci papa et maman
vraiment honte a déjà dit que tu
ressembles à malcolm alors sa maladie
mais je sais pas combien de fois
pourtant je comprends vraiment pas ce
que malcom mais ressemble à ça ah mais
moi je ressemble à ça
maki toi match et des histoires filiales
non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]